[music]
>> And
as it was, you know, we're used the word
grilled into your heads.
The most important thing for the success
of any work you're doing life, it is not
just [snorts] restricted to Dawah.
It is not just restricted to the work of
Islam. Any work that we should do in
your life.
The most important is the help of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
How many of you remember the reference?
The help of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
Masha Allah. How many of you can give me
the Arabic?
Difficult task. Only two.
English at least? English?
The translation of the meanings
of the Quranic verse.
Okay, let me ask you.
What is the reference brother Imam? The
help of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
Chapter number three, verse number 160.
The better way would be Surah Ali Imran,
chapter number three, verse number 160.
You are right. Alhamdulillah. Brother
Imran,
what is the next important thing for
success
in Dawah and any other work that we
should do?
That is in Surah Ankabut, chapter number
29. I don't remember the verse number.
It says that you have to strive hard.
>> anyone helping with the verse number?
Surah Ankabut, chapter 29, verse 69.
Masha Allah.
Allah Tabaraka wa Ta'ala says in Surah
Ankabut, chapter 29, verse number 69,
"Wal ladhina jahadu fina lanahdiyannahum
subulana." That if you strive in Allah's
way, Allah will open the pathways for
you.
So, the most important thing after the
help of Allah Subhana wa Ta'ala is
the hard work.
The striving, the jihad.
Not the jihad that which the media
portrays.
The jihad according to the Quran and
Sunnah.
Is that clear?
Brother Imran, yes. Jazak Allah. And
brother Imran,
was this your first experience of coming
on the stage
or have you given public lectures even
earlier? No, if you mean like public
lecture in front, the maximum I had was
about 10 or 9. Not like public lecture
you mean. Like kind of talk, that's it.
If I have to ask you the percentage of
difference you see
between what you had
spoken there on that stage and this
stage,
how would you give me the difference?
The difference would be like
this one is like
I cannot even
the words could not come in my mind, but
if you want to add like percentage,
inshallah, I will give
100 for this and maybe 0.1% to that.
>> Subhana Allah.
Subhana Allah.
Jazak Allahu Khairan.
And
who wants to speak next?
Okay, brother Arshi. Yes, brother Arshi.
Sorry, brother Arshi.
You're an in-house speaker for us.
Masha'Allah.
Yes.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatu Wa'alaykum
as-salam warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
Few things. Number one, this is
fantastic.
Uh alhamdulillah, state of the art. Uh
alhamdulillah, uh Zakir bhai
alhamdulillah has set a benchmark for
people to achieve that, alhamdulillah.
And as far as the israf goes, when you
talk about israf, we have to look at it
in a proper perspective. Uh when you
look at 200 million plus people
watching,
and we're going to have this for the
next 50 years, let's say, insha'Allah.
So, when you divide that the amount, it
comes to really nothing. So, you can't
really say israf. So, you can say we
need to do this in a way, insha'Allah.
That's all I have to say. As-salamu
alaykum. Okay, jazakallahu khairan. And
brother Arshi rightly said that normally
when people see such, you know,
beautiful stages with all the science
and technology, the latest in the world,
they normally think that this is israf.
But they don't realize, this has been
said multiple number of times now, the
most important thing,
or the top priority of this Dawah
training program, is the video recording
which is being done, which will
insha'Allah be aired to not less than
200 million people of the world. And in
future, insha'Allah, to more, a bigger
audiences. And if we have to take the
individuals and divide the cost, and as
brother Arshi said, it's nothing. It's
negligible.
So, not many people think this way.
And that is the reason why majority of
the people think, they have a
misconception. We will be dealing with
many misconceptions about Islam. You
know, there is one session, insha'Allah,
hoping, you know, it will be a part of
one of the days, where we'll also deal
with the people raising allegations on
the Dawah work that which normally is
done on satellite TV media. So,
inshallah, a special session will be
dealt with by Dr. Zakir Naik, wherein he
will discuss such issues, the
allegations raised by our own community,
and how a da'ee of Islam should be able
to defend it confidently following the
principles of Quran and Sunnah,
inshallah.
Our brother Abu Shareef, you seem to
look very silent. Let us make Abu
Shareef speak.
Yes. By the way, you're looking smarter
than our brother Zamri Winoth, masha
Allah.
Alhamdulillah. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh. Wa'alaikum
assalam warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
It is not the first time I have learned
that
niyah is most important and
help of Allah is the most important
thing.
I have learned this from Zakir bhai
before.
I have attended alhamdulillah quite
number of trainings,
but over the course,
we keep on forgetting that.
And we keep on going back to our old
tracks, where we concentrate on
techniques, on methods,
strategies, plannings, and so on. But we
keep on forgetting about help of Allah
and striving in the way of Allah.
So, what I feel
about this training is that
alhamdulillah summa alhamdulillah,
Zakir bhai has started with the right
foot for us, not for him, for us.
So, that
it is instilled
uh in our system
that our thinking pattern should be
evolving around the niyah and around the
right method, which is
uh looking for help of Allah,
uh striving in the way of Allah, and
then only going for the technique.
So, I think
everybody has praised
very highly about the setup.
I'm also uh on the same platform.
I've never imagined such a platform,
leave alone thinking about being on one.
My imagination doesn't come this
In Malaysia, the the best we have is a
simple banner, which costs probably 10
US dollar or maybe a simple backdrop.
>> [snorts]
>> This is This is like a dream, and I was
uh
even though it may look like a joke, but
inshallah, with [clears throat] the with
the pure intentions we have, I think
that is equally important in the in the
efforts we're making.
This training is very concentrated.
Um
I think I've realized today that there's
no time to
waste.
There's no time to joke.
I think we better um
realize how important uh and what is the
magnitude of this program, and
we need to put um a lot more focus
in the in the objectives of the program
and being
well prepared, well oiled. I mean,
personally, I'm a very weak uh and uh
and uh
a weak da'ee and a weak Muslim,
basically.
Uh in terms of preparation.
I have problem to house and remember the
references.
So, people like me, um
I know Allah will help me. Inshallah.
It's going to be difficult. It's going
to be challenging.
I'm pretty nervous and pretty scared
with the amount of homework we are
getting.
But uh I'm not going to give up,
inshallah. Alhamdulillah. That's the
spirit. Alhamdulillah. Allahu Akbar.
Allahu Akbar. Masha Um you guys
>> Alhamdulillah. Um most well prepared,
well organized, well structured, most
presentable.
And I hope uh
Allah give me the um
hidayah to live up to the expectation.
Allah has given me chance to be
presentable in this stage. Thank you,
sir. Jazakallah Khairan for your
feedback, brother Abu Shareef. But let
me make one point clear to the
participants and the audiences watching
us on Peace TV, that in no ways we are
trying to undermine the works that which
are being done by the others. In no ways
are we trying to undermine it.
The work that which we do in the cause
of Allah with whatever abilities we
have,
Allah is going to question you on your
ability, not how much you spent.
Whatever you're capable of, if your near
is good, if your intentions are good,
you're doing it for the cause of Allah
and not for anything else, not for show
off, then inshallah tabarak wa ta'ala
whatever you do, Allah tabarak wa ta'ala
is the one who bestows. He's al-Wahhab.
He bestows in abundance.
So, never despair of the rewards and
blessings of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
I guess we have very less time. We can
just take a feedback of one of you.
Inshallah, maybe brother Azlan Chan.
Brother Azlan Chan. Bismillah ir-Rahman
ir-Rahim. Assalamualaikum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Wa alaykumu
salam wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
Well, I am I feel very proud to to be
part of the participant.
I hope I can catch up.
>> [laughter]
>> Inshallah. Inshallah. If you follow the
formula for success, inshallah.
>> Yes, inshallah. Formula for success,
I'll again repeat it. Number one is the
help of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Surah
Al Imran chapter number three verse
number 160. If Allah helps you,
none can overcome you. But if Allah
forsakes you, there is none who can help
you. So, let the believers put their
trust in Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Number two, Surah Ankabut chapter 29
verse number 69. Wa alladhina jahadu
fina lanahdiyannahum subulana. If you
strive, if you struggle, if you do jihad
in the cause of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, then he will open the pathways
for you. And lastly,
though important but the least
important, is the techniques.
Allah tabarak wa ta'ala says in Surah
An-Nahl chapter number 16, verse number
43, and a similar message given in Surah
Anbiya, chapter number 21, verse number
seven. Allah says, "Fas alu ahla dhikri
in kuntum la ta'lamun." If you do not
know, then ask the people of knowledge.
Jazak Allahu Khairan for your feedbacks,
brothers.
I really enjoyed it, alhamdulillah, and
I wish that you people learn the
techniques as well as
keep reviving your intentions every time
you step inside
keep reviving your intentions for the
cause of Allah subhanahu wa'taala. Wa
akhiru da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil
alameen.
>> [music]
>> Allahu
Allahu
>> [music]
[chanting]
>> Allahu
Allahu
>> [singing]
>> Allahu
>> [music]
Allahu